[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
ikor terekhov c'est le maire de rares
qui fera re kif c'est la seconde ville
d'ukraine une ville qui est sous le feu
russe depuis le début de la guerre le 24
février il y a trois semaines merci
beaucoup monsieur le maire d'être avec
nous
je vous demandais quelle est la
situation sur place à kharkiv est ce que
les russes sont entrés dans la ville qui
contrôlent kharkiv aujourd'hui
force ça
depuis le 24 ans c'est vrai février
c'était le premier jour de cette guerre
cette guerre menée par la fédération de
russie contre l'ukraine et bien ces
forces russes et tente de rentrer dans
la ville et la ville est sous le
contrôle de l'ukraine et toutes les
tentatives qui sont entreprises
aujourd'hui par les forces russes
sont repoussés par les forces craignent
elles
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y à des
tirs en permanence
les tirs au but contre les zones
résidentielles et il y à des pertes
humaines parmi les civils
plus de 600 bâtiments à savoir 615
bâtiments à plusieurs étages ont été
détruits il y à des tirs qui visent des
zones résidentielles des quartiers
résidentiels qui visent les
infrastructures de la ville
on vise également des
centrales qui alimentent en électricité
à la ville il y a également des frères
qui sont menées pour couper le chauffage
détruire ce système
donc petit à petit l'infrastructure est
en train d'être détruites il y à des
frappes qui sont donnés contre les
établissements scolaires cinq écoles ont
été
détruites et une maternité également
il y à des tirs qui visent des épaules
des
structures de petite enfance
la destruction de masse mené par l'armée
russe
ont construit est colossal les tirs sont
nourris ils utilisent des systèmes
uniques smertch grade
et les avions larguent des bombes
c'est la situation actuelle à carcans le
bilan humain monsieur le maire est ce
que vous savez combien de personnes sont
mortes sous cet assaut que vous décrivez
bien sûr je sais ces chiffres je les
connais
plus de 500
personnes
500 civils sont morts malheureusement
alors je reparle il y a des blessés ils
sont nombreux
je peux vous dire
chaque bombardement
chaque au but qui est lancé ça augmente
ça fait augmenter ce chiffre a
malheureusement ce qu'il y à vous avez
parlé de
d'école de maternité visé est ce qu'il
ya des enfants parmi ces victimes
civiles monsieur le maire
oui bien sûr
les enfants mes enfants ont été tués et
des adultes également
quelle est la situation dans la ville
c'est une ville si je me trompe pas
qu'il y avait un million et demi
d'habitants combien d'après vous sont
partis aujourd'hui de kharkiv
la population ait été un peu plus de
messages 1500000
c'était capital mes étudiants
universitaires il y avait beaucoup
d'étudiants qui est venaient faire leurs
études à cahors
aujourd'hui
la statistique exacte le chiffre exact
est impossible à déterminer
personnes qui ont quitté la gym mais je
sais aussi que de nombreux résidents
restent en ville ils veulent pas quitter
la ville il se pose la question de
savoir pourquoi je dois quitter ma ville
natale
ma ville que j'aime dans laquelle j'ai
vécu il se pose ces questions
monsieur le maire d'après les nations
unies des bombes à sous-munitions ce
qu'on appelle aussi des bombes à
fragmentation ont été utilisés par les
russes à rare qu'il sait des
armes qui sont très très dangereuse pour
les civils est ce que vous affirmez que
ces bombes ont été utilisés et
continuent à être utilisés contre la
population civile de votre ville
ce qui concerne et les bombes à sous
munitions
oui j'ai vu
des éclats de ces aides au but
les militaires ont bien expliqué qu'il
s'agissait des bombes à sous-munitions
secte ivement la situation est très
grave alors vous avez affirmé que
les troupes russes n'ont pas réussi à
prendre kharkiv mais que du coup vous
êtes bombardé artillerie par les voies
aériennes également beaucoup de gens se
demandent si vladimir poutine va faire
de certaines villes en ukraine peut être
la vôtre ce qu'il a fait à grozny en
tchétchénie en 1999 c'est à dire rasé la
ville est ce que c'est votre plus grande
peur monsieur le maire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui personne n'a peur de rien
car cauvin parce que nous sommes sous le
feu nourri et des tirs nourris
en permanence ce que je vois aujourd'hui
je vois les zones résidentielles sont
détruites en
lisant france structure les services
urbains les réseaux de services urbains
qui alimente la ville sont visés
ainsi je vous dis très clairement ce que
je vois c'est un génocide contre notre
ville et le peuple et craignant alors
kharkiv est tout proche un 2-2 de la
russie géographiquement mais j'allais
dire même
culturellement c'est une ville à grande
majorité russophone est ce que vous
pensez que vladimir poutine
estimait que votre ville votre région
accueillerait les troupes russes avec
des fleurs et qu'il s'est trompé et que
dorénavant la population dont certains
pouvaient avoir des sympathies pour la
russie a totalement changé d'avis
aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas vous dire à ce que le
président poutine c'est un président de
la fédération de russie nous nous avons
à notre président vladimir zelensky
ces actions
seront
jugés par la portée internationale et
par et la russie maintenant en ce qui
concerne l'accueil avec des fleurs des
soldats russes tout le monde savait
parfaitement que la ville de cartes
offre est une ville ukrainienne un seul
a été dit il redit même moi j'ai les dix
est annoncée bien avant lui l'invasion
par la fédération de russie tous les
résidents de qatofin savait parfaitement
il comprenait parfaitement que qu'accor
faisait partie de l'ukraine et je vous
confirme que personne n'attendait les
envahisseurs
pour les accueillir à bras ouverts et
donc notre ville
résiste et fait tout pour mettre un
terme à cette guerre lancée par la
fédération de russie je peux vous dire
également que non résidents qui sont
russophones et bien nous sommes en faune
mais nous sommes sûrs craignant et nous
faisons partie
intégra intégrant
l'ukraine et bien en ukraine il ya une
partie shore
à l'est une partie à l'ouest et c c'est
du tout qui fait la nation c'est comme
la france qui est composé de nombreuses
régions
nous sommes unis et lorsque nous sommes
attaqués de l'extérieur
nous resterons unis pour repousser
l'attaqué vous avez parlé du président
zelensky aujourd'hui s'est adressé au
congrès des états unis l'a demandé de
fermer le ciel aux forces russes il a
dit je le cite la russie a transformé le
ciel ukrainien en source de mort à
kharkiv vous le vivez dans votre chair
si j'ose dire est-ce que vous aussi vous
appeler la communauté internationale à
fermer le ciel aux avions russes
bien où vous savez oui
j'appelle le monde entier à fermer le
ciel au dessus de l'eau fans au dessus
de carter qui plaisait j'ai parlé par
téléphone au téléphone avec des
homologues énumère
de
la ville de chicago de la ville d'austin
et je n'aurais deux membres et
l'insouciance outillant de la ville
d'oka recours et un soutien de l'ukraine
pour qu'il fasse du lobby pour pouvoir
faire cela monsieur le maire en
conclusion vous êtes à kharkov sous les
bombes vous allez rester
bien sûr
bien sûr quelle question
igor thereof merde kharkov tous merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité pour
cette édition spéciale de l'entretien
sur france24 merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi rester sur nos antennes pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]